Todd Phillips' Joker movie has finally cast
two of the most recognizable characters in
the DC Comics universe — but the choices
may raise a few eyebrows.
Per ComicBook.com, child actor Dante Pereira-Olson
is set to play a young Bruce Wayne, years
before he steps into the cape and cowl to
become Batman.
In 2015, Pereira-Olsen appeared briefly in
another comic book adaptation, Marvel's Jessica
Jones.
Acclaimed British actor Douglas Hodge will
take on the role of Alfred Pennyworth, a former
Special Operations Executive operative and
Bruce's loyal butler, and later, legal guardian
following the deaths of Thomas and Martha
Wayne.
Pereira-Olson's involvement with Joker reunites
him with Joaquin Phoenix, who plays Arthur
Fleck, the failed stand-up comedian who eventually
turns to a life of crime and becomes the Joker.
Pereira-Olson played a younger version of
Phoenix's character in the Lynne Ramsay's
psychological thriller You Were Never Really
Here.
Pereira-Olson will also act alongside Brett
Cullen, who takes on the role of Thomas Wayne.
Cullen is perhaps best known as Goodwin from
ABC's Lost and briefly appeared in Christopher
Nolan's Batman trilogy finale The Dark Knight
Rises as a kidnapped Congressman.
Traditionally, Batman plays a significant
role in the Joker's transformation into a
deranged supervillain.
Choosing a child actor to star as Bruce Wayne
opposite an adult who plays the dude who snaps
and starts terrorizing Gotham City is a bold
choice.
It subverts the idea that the Joker can't
exist without Batman — who committed himself
to vigilantism following the murders of his
parents — and that Batman can't exist without
the Joker.
"No.
No.
You...
You, complete me."
Clearly, if Bruce in this universe isn't even
a pre-teen when Joker is old enough to have
a failed career and a few wrinkles on his
face, the Joker doesn't necessarily need a
billionaire orphan in a batsuit to make him
the criminal he is.
But casting reports indicate that Cullen's
role as Thomas Wayne will be more than just
flashback fodder.
So perhaps a later act of the movie will depict
the shooting of the Waynes and place the man-who-will-be-the-Joker
behind the trigger, just as Batman '89 did.
On the other hand, there's the notion that
Bruce Wayne and the Joker are connected not
by death but by life — through none other
than Thomas Wayne himself.
Casting reports and industry gossip hint that
the Joker's mother could play a big part in
the film, and one fan theory speculates that
Batman and the Joker will be secret half-siblings.
Sure, this theory is more than a little out
there, but it does hold some weight.
In the film, Thomas Wayne is reportedly a
far less sympathetic character than he usually
is.
Instead of a talented physician and kind philanthropist
who does right by all, he's reportedly a,
quote, "cheesy and tanned businessman who
is more in the mold of a 1980s Donald Trump"
who runs for mayor of Gotham City.
Arthur might be so overtaken with anguish
and confusion following the revelation that
Thomas is his father that he grabs a gun and
shoots his biological father and his wife,
Bruce's mother Martha, as a way to gain retribution
for growing up without a father and to make
young Bruce hurt in the same way he did.
Or it might turn out that Alfred Pennyworth
and the Wayne family won't play that large
a role in the upcoming Joker film, appearing
in limited or even cameo capacities rather
than as crucial characters.
After all, the movie is all about Arthur Fleck
and his eventual change into the Joker, described
as, quote, "an exploration of a man disregarded
by society [that] is not only a gritty character
study, but also a broader cautionary tale."
Find out the truth when Joker hits theaters
October 4th, 2019.